[Music]
[Music]
was that was
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
a magazine Berkley all that fallenness
to that time was cutting his way to
power as president sentences the state
and there's a very radical strike action
against San Francisco State throughout
September October November
we need mrs. temple every day we was
right
[Music]
things I've ever seen because that Cisco
state has a bit quad with square typical
buildings on our site well the tactic
squad intelligence people to the FBI
would put their observers up on these
rooftops
obviously they also had closed-circuit
TV because it couldn't you never saw up
by a collar
you never saw meters on the corners of
the buildings and they hold rallies and
the Black Panthers would speak and some
guys would get up and say now you're
here
and building was one of the building
years that we're here for business and
the crowd would just begin moving toward
the business administration building
while the cobblestone walkways were
suddenly
[Music]
vacation ended and the next day our God
is leaving my apartment in the hills
behind Berkeley I know this guy at the
bar with a funny license plate for a
mounted on little stands they could
write while you drove and he seemed to
be taking a lot of interest in my
comings and goings so I told my friend
that we had reminded him that the first
duty of a revolutionary is to survive
right and so media bother tickets to the
ball
[Applause]
and then one to India and then back to
the states there was the possibility at
that time of getting real estate in the
Seychelles and it is really all that
traveling in Asia which pointed me for
my interest in this anarchy theme will
begin to build because we are locked in
an impossible cultural bind between a
completely exhausted and materialistic
Marxism and a completely cancerous and
and valued dark kind of capitalism
neither of these systems is tolerable
actually and they only and each feeds
off the other as its reason for being
the problem has always been with Anarchy
that people as WC Fields said are no
damn good and I think that's where
psychedelics come in the pre zijn people
are no damn good is because they have no
sense of social responsibility and it is
the cultivation of this social sense of
social responsibility that will pave the
way for anarchy and it isn't social
responsibility as preached from the
pulpit it has to be from the guts it has
to be real social responsibility and
then lo and behold the withering away of
the state and all these highly unlikely
things will actually come into view but
it will take almost a sub telepathic or
proto telepathic society for this to
happen
computer networking and that sort of
thing can provide the hardwiring for the
basic data
the banking data the statistical data
the real unconscious of the machine part
of humanity but it's human beings that
are going to make this leap to
responsibility to usher it in its the
completion of this program of obsession
with the Neolithic is the completion of
the program begun by psychoanalysis and
psychedelic drugs and you know a number
of people who might not have thought
they would end up on the same side I
mean it's the completion of the program
of Hugh Hefner and the feminists because
it will eventually it is it does have
this polymorphic sexual content but it
also is certainly a goddess a goddess
realizing kind of social this thing I
said earlier about emotions emotions are
the carrier wave of a being and we and
we have been blind to this for a very
long time
we can embrace chaos and see that chaos
is the environment in which we all
thrive that's how I've done it for years
you think I could have lived you think I
could have gotten away with this in the
Soviet Union I don't think so I require
a society on the brink of social
breakdown to be able to do my work and
and I think a society on the brink of
social breakdown is the healthiest
situation for individuals I don't know
how many of you have ever had the
privilege of being in a society in a
pre-revolutionary situation but the
cafes stay open all night and there's
music in the streets and you can breathe
it you can feel it and you know what is
happening the Dominator is being pushed
it never succeeds it never it never is
able to claim itself but on the other
hand history is young we may have we may
have a crack at this a global society is
coming into being a global society made
out of information that was not intended
to be ours but which is ours through the
mistaken invention and distribution of
small computers the printing press all
of this stuff information is power and
information has been spilled by the
clumsy handling of the cybernetic
revolution by the Dominator culture in
so that it is everywhere never has the
situation been more
would never have the opportunities for
infiltration insurrection and
hell-raising been more present at hand
but we have to seize the opportunity we
have to seize the opportunity because
the world doesn't have that much more to
run unless somebody begins to shake the
applecart
if we don't begin to shake the applecart
then the applecart is just going to sail
over the cliff and be lost
[Music]
you